charlie a tu sortiras tu te sentiras
libre comme un oiseau ici c'est presque
aussi foot là où tu es près partout a
été surprise je m'appelle florence
vcomment c'est parti il va falloir me
dire commencer votre nom à vous
sam vous avez quelqu'un d'un peu de vie
qu'est ce que tu peux savoir de moi ça
pourrait mieux se passer pour toi dans
le secteur si tu me laisses est relaxé
j'ai pas de problème dans ce secteur
d'accord tout fonctionne à merveille
celui que tu veux voir mort
pour pouvoir y arriver il faut que je
fasse plus que laisse entendre
pourquoi ça a mal tourné hier soir qui
vous a dit ça c'est toi
tuerait pas alors j'ai pu le voir
n'aie pas peur france n'ait pas peur
jamais